hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the dark
wizards of times past now when most
people hear the term dark wizard their
mind likely jumps to one of two figures
Voldemort or Grindelwald but what if I
told you that over the course of history
there were quite a few other dark
figures responsible for conducting dark
magic and or terrorizing the greater
Wizarding World today we're going to
dive in and take a look at some of these
lesser-known Wizards starting with the
oldest given that for many of these
Wizards we only have approximate dates
I'll do my best to get the order right
let's get into it rexidian rexidian was
a dark wizard who was said to have
existed during an unknown period in time
it's only referred to as ancient it was
very talented dark wizard who was fully
immersed in the dark arts able to
produce all sorts of evil concoctions
and cast all sorts of sinister spells
but one thing that they always had
trouble with was what we now know to be
the Patronus charm according to Harry
Potter law rexidian who was massively
magically talented was simply not able
to produce the Patronus charm properly
because he was not pure of heart where a
normal ritual wizard could expect to be
introduced to their spirit animal when
casting the spell for the first time
rexidian was met with maggots not only
that but they were maggots that devoured
him engulfing his body this is a
testament to just how evil ricksidian
was he wasn't just not pure of heart
residian's heart was black he was pure
evil Harper the foul Harper the fowl was
an ancient dark wizard that hailed from
Greece it's entirely unknown when Harper
walked the Earth but we do know that it
was a long long time ago as he is
commonly referred to as one of the
earliest known dark Wizards during his
existence herpa devoted his life to
producing and creating some of the worst
kinds of magic imaginable producing the
first ever basilisk
some speculated herpo is the distant
ancestor of Salazar Slytherin since he
too could speak parcel tongue herpo was
eventually immortalized in a chocolate
frog card a Chris this ecristus isn't
particularly well known but he marked
his place in Wizarding history as a
practitioner of the worst kinds of dark
arts imaginable the types of magic that
he performed and experimented with made
Voldemort's horcrux creation look fairly
commonplace a Christus was alive during
the 15th century and he is the original
inhabitant of the island Fortress of
Azkaban while traveling one day a
Christus stumbled upon the island which
at the time had no infrastructure to
speak of when he first arrived it was
just a regular Island but he soon turned
it into his own little dark arts
experiment after placing concealment
charms on the island a Christus began
his dark arts experiments by luring
muggle Sailors to the island then
torturing and eventually murdering them
before ever stepping foot on the island
a Christus was mad but after spending
some time there he became totally insane
as he completely lost touch with reality
he became so wrapped up and enthralled
in his experimentation with dark magic
that he had lost his mind and the poor
sales that he brought to the island
witnessed it firsthand in his Madness it
has been speculated that the Christus
either unwittingly or perhaps
intentionally created what we now know
to be Dementors which are the most evil
creatures in the Wizarding World Merwin
the malicious next up we have Merwin the
malicious an evil pure blood wizard that
existed in a medieval period sometime
between the 5th and 15th centuries
during his lifetime Merwin was a
dedicated practitioner of the dark arts
and would conduct all sorts of Twisted
magical experiments using his uniquely
hooked wand he had dark gray scabby
looking skin which sort of resembles
lifeless human skin and would often
sport a long dark green cloak it was a
scary looking guy but I have no doubt
that the experiments he would conduct
had a lasting effect on his physical
appearance as we know how dark magic can
affect you in that way Merwin was
single-handedly responsible for creating
a lot of the dark spells jinxes and
hexes that sprang up out of the Medieval
Era and after his death made it onto a
chocolate frog card Salazar Slytherin
Salazar Southern whose name we should
probably recognize was a pure blood
wizard that was born sometime before 976
A.D famously or rather infamously he
founded Slytherin house at Hogwarts
suthering is also Infamous for his
disliking of muckleborn students and was
a strong proponent of having only pure
blood students at Hogwarts this
philosophy was ultimately passed on to
other slytherins his response to
muggleborn students attending the school
was to build the Chamber of Secrets
which concealed a basilisk that was
intended to purge the school of these
students Emerick the evil the first
official known historical owner of the
Elder Wand is a wizard who went by the
name of Emrick the evil though the wand
may have been in the hands of other
Wizards before Emrick and after Antioch
Emrick is the first wizard on record to
have possessed it Emerick has been
described as a short-lived but
exceptionally aggressive wizard that
terrorized the south of England in the
Early Middle Ages godelow godalo was one
of the named and known owners of the
Elder Wand before it came into the
possession of the likes of gregorovich
Grindelwald Dumbledore Etc if his name
sounds doubly familiar to you it may be
because godila wrote the famous dark
magic textbook magic most evil a book
containing information on Dark Magic
including a passing reference to
horcruxes in its introduction godelow
used the Elder one to push the
boundaries of magic and considered it to
be his teacher allowing the wand to help
him write the book leveraging The
Powerful wand and using it in accordance
with his dark mindset godlow ultimately
created a lot of dark spells and curses
Godly was eventually killed by his own
son who locked him in the cellar in
order to gain ownership of the Elder
Wand Morgana lafay Morgana lafay is
actually a pseudo-historical figure and
in many versions of folklore she's the
Nemesis of the powerful wizard Merlin
though not all of them Morgana however
also exists in Harry Potter folklore
where she is portrayed as an extremely
evil wedge and again the Nemesis of
Merlin who went to Hogwarts Organa is
considered by many to be the most
powerful Witch of all time and someone
truly hated every aspect of goodness in
the world doing everything she could do
to fight against it gomla gaunt gomla
gaunt was an Irish pure blood dark wedge
and the aunt of his old Ser who founded
ilvermorny School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry gomla who attended Hogwarts
herself and was sorted into you guessed
it Southern strongly believed in pure
blood Supremacy and had an intense
hatred for anyone that went against
these extreme views her hatred went so
deep that she murdered her own sister
and brother-in-law she also shared
something in common with Voldemort she
had an inability to feel love gormla may
not have caused widespread turmoil in
The Wizarding World but she certainly
terrorized to a family Barnabas devrel
another previous owner of the Elder Wand
Barnabas devil was a wizard from the
early 18th century who earned quite the
reputation as a fearsome warlock to put
things plainly devil certainly didn't
use the wand for good and for many years
he leveraged the powerful wand to
tyrannize The Wizarding World however
eventually his reign of terror ended
when he was defeated by a rival Wizard
loxius and here we have yet another
previous owner of the Elder Wand loxius
is the man who famously gave the Elder
one the name the Death Stick and
ruthlessly murdered copious amounts of
people while using it loxius was a truly
Evil dark wizard that many wanted dead
and according to Dumbledore many claimed
to have been the one to finish him off
even his own mother and that's it for
this video if you want more info on
these evil wizards then please leave a
comment down below also if you enjoy the
content please be sure to like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]